I want to ask you first of all briefly I
hope about the whole Dominic Cummings
affair as we know a lot of elected
Conservative MPs are listening to their
constituents and saying that they're not
satisfied with the explanations given by
Dominic Cummings and the Prime Minister
they do believe he broke the rules when
many other people in similar difficult
circumstances didn't and they think he
should go why are they wrong
well good morning Adam
Dominic Cummings has given his detailed
explanation to the Prime Minister the
Prime Minister asked him to say that
publicly on Monday to answer questions
from the media which he did for for over
an hour answering every question sorry
my question please I'm asking you I'm
not asking about what he said we know
what he said we carried it live here on
Sky News the point is a lot of your
colleagues elected MPs unlike mr.
Cummings don't think his answers are
satisfactory and I'm saying why are they
wrong the Prime Minister and I agree
with him believe that he's acted
reasonably and within the law he evade
the guidelines
I appreciate that many people across the
country including many of my colleagues
in Parliament believe that he made the
wrong decisions but he did behave within
the guidelines and so I believe I think
the Prime Minister does as well that we
should now move forwards okay well a lot
of people were feeling about your own
behavior that also got the thumbs up
from the prime minister so it does look
a little bit as if there's one law for
you and a different law for everyone
else and indeed a law which has been
enforced on the rest of us
that's not that there's other gates
nobody is exceptional here everybody has
to obey the same rules and with respect
to Dominic Cummings he did obey the
guidelines the guidelines say that if
you have children you should try to
follow the rules to the very best of
your ability but they do allow you to
use a degree of discretion is not in his
job we know also that dr. cold award is
not in her job but your in your job
Dominic Cummings is in his job I do want
to ask you about something in The Times
today it says it seems extraordinary to
me that you've admitted that you showed
apparent bias in unlawfully intervening
to approve a planning decision in favor
of Richard Desmond's company in London
when the council and the inspector had
ruled against it so you admit you showed
apparent bias towards a Tory donor well
and so appropriate for me to get into
individual planning applications
obviously as housing secretary it's a
matter of record you have mitad
admitting apparent bias in this case and
what does that mean well I can assure
you that we took this decision as we do
all decisions on the merits we
absolutely refute any suggestion of bias
but we did wait a minute either you've
admitted a parent bias as reported in
The Times today or you haven't have you
admitted a parent bias no we said that
there there is no bias but that because
issues were raised for absolute fairness
we would quash the decision and enable
it to be retaken if that's what the
applicant wants and that will be retaken
as is the usual way by a different
Minister so that was done for complete
fairness and the decision if the
applicant wishes to do so can be retaken
at a later stage
well the applicant of course is the
person who benefits from this so I don't
think that's particularly meaningful
but this is being quoted I just want to
get this on the record have you admitted
officially this is what the times is
saying that you showed quotes apparent
bias in unlawfully intervening to
approve this planning application well
the the way that the court process works
is that if you want to retake the
decision then you have it quashed in the
court that's what that's what we've done
and that enables it to be retaken if the
applicant wishes that to be the case we
obviously don't believe that we acted
inappropriately or that we showed up I'm
just trying to establish the fight here
The Times is reporting not just read it
out to you that you have accepted that
you showed apparent bias in unlawfully
intervening to approve this application
by Richard Desmond's company a man who
supports the Conservatives and has
donated to the Conservatives I'm just
asking you factually in the legal
process have you admitted that you
showed apparent bias the legal process
sets out that the the way the decision
was taken could give rise to the
appearance of bias but obviously we
reject that there was any actual bias
and that's why for complete fairness the
department decided that the decision
could be retaken by a different Minister
and that may well happen if the
applicant wishes to do so in the future
because of course the reason why the
inspector and the counsel were against
it was because there wasn't enough
social housing enough housing for poor
people well I hope you'll respect this
so it's not appropriate me to get into
the details of individual your you've
taken a decision in this case so I think
it is appropriate just explain it is
true that the government is keen to get
more homes built and there's a
consistent record by this government and
indeed by Mia's secretary of states that
we've tried to ensure that homes get
built
particularly in London where development
has been too slow
in recent years so we have weren't
enough affordable homes social houses
for the people who need them there may
have been apartments for rich people who
live abroad and that may help mr.
Richmond mr. Desmond's company but the
issue is this is a typical example of a
scheme in London where it is said there
weren't enough social houses and you
have intervened to approve it if that's
the circumstance isn't it
well that isn't that isn't quite right
it's obviously it is more complicated
than that but it is correct that we
judged that the benefit of more homes
outweigh some of the other concerns with
the project more expensive so fewer
fewer cheaper homes and more expensive
homes across the country well we want to
get more homes of all kinds built
obviously in the right places and you
judge each application on its own merits
but we want to get more homes built of
all kinds we're doing that in a number
of different ways
supporting developments but also
investing in affordable housing as well
and we're bringing forward the largest
ever affordable homes program for
example it was announced at the budget
that will enable us to build thousands
more homes which are available to people
on low incomes we're also bringing
forward our signature homeownership
policy first homes that will give a 30%
discount to first-time buyers and to key
workers like nurses and care workers to
get their first step on the house just
one final question on this issue with
hindsight do you accept that you were
wrong to intervene and you shouldn't
have approved this development
well we judged it on the merits and that
was done without any actual bias but
clearly the way that the process was run
gave rise to some concerns and so that's
why we've chosen to quash the decision
by agreement with the other parties and
to have it read a term is the fairest
way to proceed now
now you've been widely praised for the
action the government's taken to deal
with the homeless homelessness cheering
this pandemic most of them I don't know
how many but how many people have been
taken into accommodation or off the
streets
well we've helped about 15,000 people
off the streets and into temporary but
safer accommodation like hotels and B&Bs
to protect them from the pandemic and
that's probably saved hundreds of
people's lives but now there's a big
task ahead of us as to how we can ensure
that as few of those people as possible
end up back on the streets when the
lockdown measures are eased and so the
first step and I think it is a
significant one that we're bringing
forward this week it's saying that we're
going to be buying or building 6,000 new
homes which are going to be made
available to those people who are
previously sleeping rough they're going
to be brought forward over the next two
years and with each of those homes will
also be wraparound care because rough
sleeping is as much a crisis of mental
health and addiction as it is one of
housing and so the individuals have move
into these homes will get support as
well on the health side so they can
begin to rebuild their lives does that
mean then that the 15,000 have being
accommodated now will be kept in that
accommodation till those homes are ready
ie for the next two years not
necessarily a lot of that accommodation
is temporary it's hotels who may well
wish to return to their usual business
when they're able to do so in the weeks
and months to come and so we'll need to
use a range of different options to look
after people appropriately until they
can be moved into the kind of good
quality move on accommodation that we
want to bring forward and we have a task
force led by Dame Louise Casey who's a
recognized national debt expert in this
field to try to help us through that
process we're also working very closely
with local councils and together we're
going to be bringing forward
accommodation but it's obviously our
objective that nobody who is in that
temporary accommodation today
back onto the street or at the very
least we've offered them a better
alternative if they want to take it up
so they we won't see 15,000 people
effectively being tipped out back onto
the streets
no I strongly hope that does not that's
not the case this is challenging I
accept that and I can't promise you that
every person will end up in the kind of
accommodation that we want and will be
able to rebuild their lives but our
objective is to offer each of those
people better accommodation and that
that can then in time lead to the move
on accommodation that we're going to
bring forward as a result of this four
hundred million pounds investment and
this will be the largest investment in
move on accommodation for rough sleepers
we've ever had as a country the largest
since the rough sleeping initiative was
created by a predecessor of mine Sir
George Young in the early 1990s so it is
a big step forward but I don't
underestimate the scale of the challenge
ahead because we're dealing with
understandably complex individuals who
will need a lot of support to enable
them to to move forward I mean I
understand that but do you not think
that this crisis the way it's been
handled the success of it shows what
John Byrd and and other people are
saying for many years that are kind of
managed almost compulsory hostile
hostile program for the homeless people
is actually the way to eliminate the
problem
well I think it's only true that if you
can get people into accommodation you
know housing first as we call it that
that is the best way then to begin to
build up people and put the care around
them and that's the approach that we're
going to be taking forward now in this
whole reconstruction process which is
going to come after the lockdown whether
you as a minister are saying to the
Treasury look why don't we make some of
these hotels permanent and deal with the
problem that way because relative to the
cost of everything else furlough and all
the rest that would be quite low
wouldn't it well we've secured four
hundred and thirty million pounds to
bring forward these six thousand homes
and to ensure they've got the right
support around them we've also got a
hundred and twelve million pound a year
rough sleeping initiative so there are
quite large sums of money being invested
if we need to secure more funding then
obviously I'll be fighting for that with
the Treasury because there's matters to
us and it would be a huge missed
opportunity as a country if we allow
people to drift back onto the streets
unnecessarily it might be that we do
purchase some of the hotels that people
have been staying in but we've got to
make sure that we find safe good quality
accommodation that's right for the
individuals and that's exactly what
we're going to set out to do now in the
weeks ahead